いよいよ zx 聖光学院ハイスクールも大詰めに差し掛かり
本日ラストの登壇者として話させていただくのは高校2 a のおり戦績です
今回僕が話したいテーマはコミュニティと意見皆さんにとっても比較的馴染みの深い
言葉とそして創造力というあまりコミュニティとは関係性のないような言葉の
組み合わせです
まず最初に僕の話に入る前に皆さんに質問があります
皆さんは今コミュニティーに属していますかて質問です
おそらく多くの場合この質問に対する答えは yes でしょう
例えば部活動であったりとかあるいは同好会行ったり
そしてこの聖光学院という学校に通っている
これもコミュニティの形の一つでしょう
ちなみに僕の場合も中学までは野球部
そして高校からはオーケストラ部という林楽オーケストラ部という幅広い部活に所属し
ていました
今皆さん頭の中に自分の所属しているコミュニティで活躍する姿や自分の仲間の姿を
思い浮かべていてください
そのコミュニティ本当に行かせていますか
これが今回僕から皆さんに対する問題提起です
僕のこの樹脂製分間のプレゼンを通して皆さんにこの答えを導いてもらいたいです
さきほども言いましたこのコミュニティと創造力という一見何の繋がりも見えない言葉
しかし
僕は
このコミュニティを生かすことができればそれが新しい創造力になると考えます
僕は中学3年生の時生徒会委員という新しい制度が始まって生徒会役員が幅広い学年
から招集され僕はその世界その時から生徒会 in 世界に飛び込み
高1では副生徒会長講義では生徒会長という計算年間にわたって聖光学院の生徒会で
携わってきました
ちなみにこの3年間という数字はおそらく成功史上初のことのでいわゆる生徒会の
プロフェッショナルといってもが込んではありません
しかしあと数字都合で権力を失います
2018年8月これは僕にとって大きな一大きな時期でありました
それは
高1の月に衆参の通算の奴に参加したボストン研修です
この左の写真は mit の
マイレずっとさせんで右の写真はタフツ大学の学生様への前で撮った写真です
まあポーズに関しては若気の至りということでお許しいただきたいんですけどもまぁ
この研修どんな研修だったかっていうと実際に自分の目で起業家の姿を見たりあるいは
現地の大学生と話したり様々話を聞く中で
やっぱり自分の中に何か新しいことをしたいとか自分の中で何か大きなことをしたい
そんな風に思えるようになりました
そして2019年4月先ほどのボストン研修から帰国を僕はそのボストン厳守で出会っ
たのかもと
学生団体を立ち上げされに他校の生徒ん巻き込み
だから学生団体の上を行ってきました
そこで2019年の7月あることが起きました
ちなみにこれこの写真僕は何処にいると思いますか
ここにいます今では考えられないねっ秀逸ですけどこれ何が起きたかというと学生団体
総選挙っていうイベントが開かれてこの総選挙では学生団体
前戦国から約110072団体集まった
主に大学生が運営する学生団体の中で自身の
活動術的であったりとか自身の未来図を語り合うというプレゼンコンテストです
この中で僕たちの学生団体は部門グランプリに輝いことができ
賞金でいえば約20万円手に入ることができます
さらにその学生団体の活動のなかで様々な人に出会いました
その一人がテレビリサーチャーという仕事をしている方です
そのテレビリサーチャーという形の仕事はテレビという私たちの
父王そしてテレビの中というあまり触れたことのない世界
そしてリサーチという私たちが普段検索だったりとが google を使う
そのようなシステムを組み合わせた人の話でとても面白かったね
この面白さを生徒のみんな
と共有したいっていう思いから
2019年11月えんした家庭科という学校の授業でその方及びして約2コマ分の授業
を自分の体棄却して行いました
その他にも自分の中でボストン県指令であった
シェアであった方のお話だったりとか自分の中で感銘を受けた方に異性と回答コラボし
ていただけないかということで生徒会企画に読んだり
今学期1学期に開催したオンライン客エイチラボトロント大学生とまずは1カイケとの
この外部の具
コミュニティと号表紙た生徒会のイベントです
ここで皆さん気づきませんか
僕はここで思いました
なんか community 繋がってね
そうです
僕はここでコミュニティの連鎖反応が起きていることに気づいたのです
自分のメインである学校生徒会の仕事
そこできっかけをもらった研修に参加してその研修で出会った中本学生団体を立ち上げ
てさらにその学生団体いう性質で学生団体を運営していく中で出会った方をさらに学校
に読んでそんな
コミュニティの連鎖反応が起きていたのです
このように様々な活動をしているかでやはり今年度大きな問題となっただったのがこの
中の影響です
今年度生徒会ではこの中の影響でたくさん悩むことがありました
例えばタイムスケジュールはすごくなりました
その例として自分が生徒会長としてほかの生徒会役員にある丸い市まるまるジェニー
会議をやるから絶対参加しろよって連絡しておきながら当日のその日
中は優雅によるご飯を食べていてオスれていました
そんな風に周りからの制限が薄いため自分で忘れてしまうなんてことも多々あったよう
に感じます
その中でもたくさんの悩みがあった中で一番困ったことが
想像力です
この想像力
自分が2年間今まで生徒会役員を詰めてきてあ
今までこうだったから今年度はこうしようなんて色々計画していただけれ
その中でこのないかという厳しい急な厳しい状況に関してどうやったら生徒会動かせる
かどうやったら生徒に満足してもらえるようが政策を起こせるかこれを想像するのは
大変
難しかったです
主に想像力には2つあると考えます
一つ目は0から1を生み出すしから
そして2つめが
依存する二つ以上の物事を掛け合わせる力です
一つ例を挙げてみましょう
この方は誰かわかりますか
これは切りスカのイギリスの科学者ティムバーナーズリーという形です
この方は今私たちが普段使っている web システムを構築した
web システムの生みの親といわれています
このような犬研究者であっているとか科学者
あとは発明家というのは先ほど言った0から1を生み出す力を持つ人と私は考えます
ついて
こちらわかりますか
こちらはフェイスブックの創業者マークザッカーバーグです
このような実業家であっているとかあるいは企業家っていうのは実は0から1を
作り出すシュートも限らず周りにある既存の二つ以上のものを組み合わせていることが
多いんです
一つでもう一つ例を出してみましょう
明日ですねく想像力はか刻んだこれが今回僕のテーマで僕のプレゼンで強調したいこと
です
これが一つの例になります
西深井クラスルーム始動これはどういうことかというとこのこのプレゼンもそのまま
なんてこのスライドもそのままで僕が公一副生徒会長の時にこれが立案した棄却です
この生徒会クラスルームというのは
今まで性とかいっていうのとクラスルームというのは
掛け合わせることのなかったものですが google クラスルームっていうのが
学校の先生それも若い先生の一部が
情報の一部を事業の補足をするために使っていた
クラスルームと生徒会の運営を掛け合わせることで何か面白いことができるんじゃない
か
須藤良いと思いたら
この政策を作りました
そのほかにも今年度行った企画として生徒会かける youtube かける学校紹介
この竹山によって生まれたのが
成功歳で行ったオンライン成功ツアー2020です
この動画は現在再生回数は4000回以上突破していて
より良い受験生にとってよりよい情報を伝えられているのではないかと思います
ついて生徒会かけるウビ会議サービスかけるアルファ
これで何が起きたかというと
今年度を行ったオンラインでのイベントです
例えばオンライン部活動体験会普段は体験することのない他の部活を再建できる会で
あったりとかあとはさ強度も上げた大学生と者段階ができる曲
そんな計画を今年度を行ってきました
さてそれではこの今回行っている鉄塔 x 成功学には何の掛け算で生まれたと思い
ますか
正解はペット x 成功学にハイスキル
この x と掛け算をかけているわけなんですけどもは彼の成功がピンという
まあ一種個性がすごい豊かでうそんな生徒もいてさらにそれを応援してくれる
個性豊かな先生方もいいでそんな環境だからこそこの今回の棄却馬が生まれたんじゃ
ないかなって思います
ます
じゃあこういった掛け算ってどうやって生まれるんだろうって思いませんか
結論から言います
最適な舁き山を導くには足し算が必要です
これいったいどういうことなのかというと例えば先ほど挙げた政府開脚の樹約半分以上
は僕の立案ではなくお花の精とか役員のメンバーの立案によるものです
つまりその最適な掛け算を導く案は案をたくさん出す必要があってさらにそれに伴い
失敗もたくさん繰り返す必要があります
そんな中例えば生徒会役員だねは約20人のメンバーの想像力を働かせさらに今年度の
成功歳であったら
約1千人以上の木客1千人以上の全校生徒から企画を集めそんな地道な足し算が必要な
んです
一度まとめます
そもそも僕はコミュニティーと想像力の話をしていました
つまり community
コミュニティに対して怨嗟反動であったりとかあるいは足し算掛け算といった
コミュニティをどうやって生かすかというのを意識することで
そこに時代を切り拓く新しい創造力が生まれるのです
今年度僕はこの中で一人同意すれば今年度1年間生徒会動かせるのか
自粛期間中すごく悩む時期がありました
それはやはりひとり抱えていたからであって
実際それを他のメンバーに聞いてみるとほかのメンバーはいろんな企画を出してくれ
たり
こうしたらいいじゃないかとアイデアおくれそうすることで今年この中においても約
40万以上の企画書を作り上げ
様々な生活政策を行えたんじゃないかと思います
最初に質問したこのそのコミュニティ本当に行かせていますかという話
結論から言うとこの質問に対して答えを出すことは難しいのではないかと思います
コミュニティーはどうやっていいかスカそしてそれを最大限に生かせた
それは最大限に生かすということはなかなかできる事でありません
コミュニティの可能性は無限大です
これから皆さんは大学に行ったり社会に出て様々なコミュニティに属することがあると
思います
そのコミュニティの現段階に満足するのではなくその管理ティをどうやって生かすか
どうやって最大限に貸すかを考えてみてください
そうすれば新しい時代を切り開く想像力が生まれるはずですご清聴ありがとうござい
ました